oh my God I'm gonna lose my best friend  I remember a conversation we had after  7-Eleven behind the store sitting on the  curb you were like hey I don't know if  this is for me I'm thinking about moving  to Boston you said to me you wanted to  do more and I remember it was a  Crossroads for it was an early lesson in  my career of oh my God I'm gonna lose my  best friend I was micromanaging the fun  stuff and we both liked the buying and  selling and writing of emails but oh I'm  keeping the stuff I love to do uh oh he  loves the same stuff I love to do which  is why we became friends in the first  place I need to relinquish some of it  and it was an early lesson in me being  thoughtful about micromanaging it's  really easy not to micromanage when  everyone else is doing [ __ ] that you  don't want to be doing but when you have  something that's great that also wants  to do the same things you better learn  real fast how to share the ball